[Music]
hey everyone so i'm back again for a
quick lightning talk
uh after i saw tim's talk on css i
couldn't resist
and i wanted to add in
a javascript uh pranks demo for you guys
so if you
can prank in css i'm gonna prank in
javascript as well
so there's this website here i made i'm
gonna go over some of the code
with you guys really quickly we can see
how to troll in javascript
okay so um this is very ad hoc so
apologies for the
informality of this okay so uh one thing
you can do is some websites on the
internet they actually let you log out
uh the site with a get request um so if
you visit this uh these urls here you'll
be logged out of those sites
well guess what any website on the
internet can make get requests
by putting those urls into an image tag
and that will uh log you out
so let's go ahead and iterate over this
and just log you out of everything when
you visit the site why not right
um let's see what else um
let's see okay here's a good one so uh
no sorry it's down here uh
yes okay this is this one is amazing so
when you link to a website
and you add via target equals
a blank underscore blank to the link
that opens the link up in a new tab
but it also sets a property called
window.opener
on that child window and that property
is a reference back to the parent window
that opened you
and using that reference you can set
window.opener.location
and navigate the window that linked to
you so
for example you send a link to this site
to your friends and me in
facebook messenger and the site you land
on
navigates the facebook messenger window
to the same troll site so it takes over
the other tab
pretty cool
this is a standard troll trick so this
one lets you
confirm that the user really wants to
leave the website that they're that
they're on so when they try to close the
tab they have to see another prompt
window here's another good one
let's register every protocol handler
that we can in the browser
so when you click on these links it will
try to redirect you to this site
this one has a permission prompt so it's
not that effective but
you can try to do it anyway while we're
at it let's try to get access to the
camera and the mic
basically we're just putting everything
we can into this site just all the apis
let's just try to just do everything we
can
um oh this is a good one did you know if
you call window.navigator.vibrate you
can make
android phones vibrate and there's no
permission required for that so let's
just vibrate the phone randomly
why not um let's intercept every click
and key press uh let's use a safari
picture-in-picture video
when you click on the page let's focus
open a bunch of pop-up windows and
bounce them around the screen
let's focus those windows every time you
interact with any of the windows
let's hide the mouse cursor with see it
with a css rule so you don't know where
the mouse is
so it's hard to go and close the windows
let's trigger a file download every time
you click on anything
why not this is the code to move the
window around
this is a code to play videos inside the
pop-up windows
um how much time do i have uh you've got
a clock in front of you
145. okay i'm going to take the last
minute to demo it
uh okay every time you click we can copy
stuff to your clipboard so let's copy a
ascii picture of a cat and that's right
here
one of these cats copy it to your
clipboard along with a link handy link
to this website
so when you paste it in by accident to
your friends it will get
it will get spread further um and what
else do i got to show
um there's a few more things i will show
with some alerts
let's request full screen so on and so
forth anyway you get the idea let's see
it in action
okay this is safari we're gonna go to
the annoying site.com
okay oh some files are being downloaded
do i'm sure i want to give camera access
to the site okay don't allow
okay all right we're good i'm gonna try
to click on this cat
oh no oh no what's going on here
okay let me just leave the page okay now
i'm in full screen mode i don't know
what's going on let me close this window
leave page i have some pop-ups flying
around
let me try to close these if you
accidentally click on the window then it
alerts that a cat comes up and then it
also does a picture-in-picture full
screen video over here
in the os if you try to close that then
okay it goes back
uh if you try to hit command w to close
the window it triggers a print dialog
window
so actually it intercepts the command w
can't close the window
um the x button is also uh removed here
okay let's try again command w oh no
basically the the moral of the story is
the web platform is very powerful
and it lets you do very many things
and oh yeah this is a good one this one
does bing searches for very
intimidating uh terms and it doesn't
over h2 actually i guess it's https but
it tries to do it over http
so that it'll get added to your uh oh
yeah it also gets added to your web
history
so you go uh history and all those
searches like why do i always have
diarrhea for example is added to your
web history
anyway that's my talk thanks